the 2022 midterms are upcoming and today
we take a deep dive into the candidates
what's at stake
what happens after the midterms and what
to expect between now and november of
this year one of the things i try to
avoid on this show is to be hyperbolic
and when people are going crazy about
something and it's really no big deal i
try to just say this is really not that
big of a deal let's talk about it but
let's talk about it in sort of sober and
reasonable terms but
that is very much not the case when it
comes to the peril that
is on the horizon
if republicans were to win the 2022
midterm elections in what are just a few
months now uh quite frankly and when i
say
democracy is in jeopardy if republicans
take the house in 2022
i say it with the caveat that this is
not a hyperbolic claim
and increasingly i mean the the bad
thing is that democracy is in peril if
republicans win the good thing is
increasingly people are understanding
this peril and this risk
republicans and democrats who are so
similar on so many issues we've talked
about it before here's a whole bunch of
issues on which there's really no
significant difference between
republicans and democrats how could it
be
that if republicans take one chamber of
congress
it would have such a major impact and
the answer is that
it is because of the destructive
potential that the series of events that
could be unleashed by republicans taking
control of the house
is so significant that it could be the
catalyst for a disaster for democracy
and let's just think it through
first we know that republicans see their
2020 failure
as a failure to steal the election what
i mean by that is when you hear
republicans talk about 2020 most of them
i mean okay mitt romney's the exception
liz cheney's the exception but for the
most part when you hear trump
people associated with the trump white
house the more weaponized republicans in
the house and senate when they talk
about what happened in 2020
their view is
we
we just didn't do enough
to take the election from the guy who
won it they don't think you know next
time we should really win by appealing
to more voters and getting more people
to vote for us that would be the normal
reaction that would be the pro-democracy
reaction not enough we didn't convince
enough people let's be better at
convincing people to vote for us no they
think we can win next time by better
working to take the election even when
we don't win it using different
techniques or being better with the
techniques that we used in 2022 but we
just didn't do enough of so with a
midterm 2022 win
they would be far better to carry out
that
um
upending of democracy in 2024 that's a
very dangerous thing secondly
marjorie taylor greene
matt gates
and others in that uh cohort have said
if we win in 2022
we're going to investigate joe biden
we're going to investigate hunter biden
who has nothing to do with the
administration we will end the january
6th committee if it's still going on we
will impeach joe biden and on and on and
on they've said that that's what they're
going to do
disaster and thirdly they've said if
they win
they will quickly work
to help the trump rioters avoid
consequences to any extent that they can
effectively rewarding the rioters for
what they did on january 6th of 2021.
now in response to this nancy pelosi who
i am not a fan of
nancy pelosi recently said quote it is
absolutely essential for our democracy
that we win i fear for our democracy if
the republicans were ever to get the
gavel we can't let that happen and some
people are like oh she's being
hyperbolic but remember that canadian
political scientist thomas homer dixon
who we interviewed recently he also
wrote and explained to us during the
interview that the united states could
be under a right-wing dictatorship by
2030 and when i asked him well what talk
to us about the sequence what are the
initial steps
and the precursor steps to a right-wing
dictatorship in 2030 include trump
winning in 2024
and a precursor to that would of course
be republicans taking the house
in 2022. so the stakes are absolutely
huge and if we just say what's most
likely i'm not saying throw in the towel
i'm not saying don't try if anything
what i'm saying is we've got to try the
more likely outcome even though nancy
pelosi won't admit it is that
republicans take the house in 2022. if
nothing significant changes republicans
only have to flip five seats remember to
take control of the house in november
that's the most likely outcome that they
are able to flip at least five seats it
is a very small margin of error for
democrats now the other aspect to all of
this is of course
is the department of justice going to
act at all
to show that what took place in 2020
simply cannot happen again and truly
hold people accountable i uh
you know i i have no emotional
investment in merrick garland one way or
the other but it's increasingly looking
like merrick garland is sort of
spineless and we're going to talk later
trump is again asking putin to help him
find dirt on people this time hunter
biden will talk about that a little bit
later in the show
but it doesn't seem merrick garland
wants to do anything we've got these
manhattan investigators who resigned
including mark pomerance saying
we had good evidence that trump
committed crimes
if we tried some of these cases
we would likely win
but it doesn't seem any charges are
coming there and multiple prosecutors
have resigned as a result a federal
judge recently said and we talked about
it earlier this week it's pretty
apparent that donald trump committed
felonies and yet
what
nothing
the department of justice seems to be
completely feckless and you have to
understand that this is bigger than just
merit garland in general number one the
checks and balances that we have
are checks and balances
but they never accounted for someone
like trump they just didn't and we
talked about this during the trump era
and the federal bureaucracy in general
has never really held president
accountable in any serious way so about
10 different things have to happen
including democrats earning more votes
the doj taking this seriously and
unfortunately
uh
it sort of seems like many democrats are
more willing to allow the possibility of
democracy dying than to take the gloves
off and saying hey you know what we do
have to do some unprecedented things but
that's because we've already had
unprecedented circumstances the trump
presidency was already unprecedented and
when that's the case
you might have to take unprecedented
action very scary times ahead
and it is not hyperbolic to say
that democracy is in peril
as yet another example of this
let's talk about
yet another request from donald trump to
vladimir putin you know on this show
sometimes we'll look at the wacky and
zany and kooky things that right-wingers
say and we'll laugh and we'll say oh
it's so silly and it's so dumb but
we don't necessarily
always
worry for the future
of humanity
and the united states
and our legislative bodies on the basis
of you know every random thing that
marjorie taylor green or whoever
necessarily says
i have an example today of something for
you
that does make me really worried about
the future of american democracy quite
frankly um because of the level of
ignorance that it shows
combined with a sort of brazen
confidence despite that ignorance
and the reality
that this may be someone who is going to
be one of only 100 senators in the
united states
herschel walker is a trump endorsed
republican senate candidate running in
the state of georgia
and herschel walker recently asked you
know
if there's evolution if evolution is
real and we humans homo sapiens
evolved from apes
why
are there still apes on the planet if
the apes evolved to become humans
why are there still apes
we're going to look at the video in a
moment
there are more than 331
million people in the united states
only 100 at a time get to be members of
one of the most powerful legislative
bodies in the country the united states
senate
one of those 100 might be someone who
questions
the truth
of evolution
because there are still
monkeys
on planet earth
let's take a look at the clip this is
this is genuinely depressing it really
brings me it's i i have fear and despair
because of this i have no
pleasure this is not fun
here that means somebody up there had to
say let there be light that the earth
started and then he had to put someone
there on earth because remember adam was
there
remember adam came there then eve came
so somebody had to start it out
so that means it had to be a god because
they didn't just some bomb blew up and
started out and then i'd tell you
something now
we're gonna get to the really crazy part
this idea that listen
if there was some first human here's the
first human because you start this that
this is not new stuff we're treading on
very worn ground here
the idea that you sometimes hear from
creationists is well okay listen
i came from a human mother
and my mother came from a human mother
and my grandmother came from a human
mother and so if you just follow that at
some point there was the first human
mother
and therefore that person must have been
created like that by a god or higher
power and of course when you understand
the slow process of evolution
and you understand how that works
you realize that the premise is wrong
it's logical to think
if ad infinitum
it was my mom and her mom and her mom
and her mom and her and it was just all
modern humans right you might end up
saying well i mean somebody must have
designed and created that first human
but we understand that that's not the
case so this alone we could spend an
hour on but let's get to the really
wacky part that's getting a lot of
attention as i heard now think about
this
because at one time science said man
came from aids it's not at one time but
by the way but yeah okay
did it not
i've read that's when you go to it every
time i read or hear that i think to
myself you just didn't read the same
bible i did well this was interesting
though
if that is true
why are there still apes
think about it you know now you're
getting too smart for it no no no think
about this we have an evolution that is
we've gotten so intelligent that if that
is true why are there still apes and
then the conception of a baby
let me tell you science can't do that
they still trying to do it but it can't
because there had to be a god
so when god came
okay
now
this is not actually a crazy question i
mean you go you know you go to third or
fourth grade
when
i think that's when kids start being
taught about evolution
there are lots of curious
uh naive wide-eyed bushy-tailed eight
and nine-year-olds who would say hey but
if we came from apes why are there still
apes didn't the apes become human and of
course there's an answer
humans did not evolve from a modern
living ape like a modern chimpanzee
we evolved and descended from a common
ancestor of apes we share
a common ancestor that's the best
science we have right now
which lived and died
in the distant past and that means we're
related to other apes
and we and those other apes came from an
earlier ape of some kind
now
that's an eight or nine year old that
would ask that
imagine if herschel walker becomes a
senator i mean really think think you
know we have 331 million people in this
country to pick from some of them are
kids so we're not literally okay but
we've got hundreds of millions of people
to choose from
how do we solve really serious problems
in this country inequality
poverty
education
hunger uh climate change
when we have a hunt it's just a hundred
people in the senate and at least one of
them may there might be others in the
senate who believe the same stuff but
when one of your hundred is a senator
saying
if evolution is real why are there still
apes on planet earth
how do we solve problems if that's the
case
we can't
and so when we wonder man why
politics is so log jammed and we just
we're not getting anywhere and it's
these you know
trivial arguments about stupid stuff and
people getting fined for not wearing
masks and people who think the vaccines
modify your d how
we have 331 million people
the senate has 100 members representing
those people
and a guy who's saying if we if
evolution is real why are there still
monkeys on earth has a genuine shot at
becoming one of those hundred and is
endorsed by former president donald
trump
it doesn't bode well
it doesn't bode well and it is not funny
it stopped being funny a while ago don't
forget that the best way to support the
david pakman show is by becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show the regular show with
no commercials you also get access to
our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
i want to talk about a ridiculous
performance by pennsylvania republican
senate candidate mehmet oz and this is
the guy many know it as dr oz
we are
doing everything we can to just refer to
him as mehmet oz
because
saying dr oz almost it's like is useful
to him in some way um oz is running in
pennsylvania as i mentioned the leading
democratic primary opponent is a guy
named john fetterman who we're going to
try to get on the show very interesting
candidate and mehmet oz
apparently wanted to make the point that
groceries are expensive this is part of
the inflation story that republicans
have been telling but republicans don't
want to tell the story in good faith
there's been inflation gas prices are
high
but it's not joe biden's fault this is
happening globally but republicans want
to tell the story that it is joe biden's
fault so what mehmet oz did is make a
very performative trip to a local
grocery store
and his point at the grocery store is
look how expensive it is to buy some
vegetables this is actually an
opportunity for memit oz to do something
useful at the grocery store but he
doesn't and i'm going to explain that in
a second let's first take a look at the
video i thought i'd do grocery shopping
i'm at weg nurse and my wife wants some
vegetables for crudite right so
here's a broccoli that's two bucks
without the ton of broccoli there
there's some asparagus that's four
dollars yep
carrots
that's four more dollars that's ten
dollars of vegetables there and then
we need some guacamole that's four
dollars more
and
she loves salsa yeah salsa there
six dollars
must be a shortage of salsa guys that's
twenty dollars for crude this doesn't
include the tequila i mean that's
outrageous we got joe biden to thank for
this
okay so he pick he makes a show by the
way do we believe he's really there
shopping i don't he makes a show of
picking up a two dollar
piece of broccoli and a four dollar
asparagus and a four dollar it's an
enormous bag of carrots for four i think
it's a five pound bag uh four dollar
guacamole six dollar salsa so it's
twenty dollars for his crudite
ingredients so first of all salsa for
no that's the first red flag here that
makes absolutely no sense why why are
you getting salsa
for crudite but that's a culinary
critique but it exposes that this is
probably all bs but secondly
it's obviously super staged to make a
political point he's not out really
shopping for crudite to make for his
guests it's absurd it's like when mitt
romney went out to shop
and all he had in his cart was just
boxes and boxes of yogurt and i think
like seltzer it was really weird it
wasn't believable it was during his
presidential campaign but this is really
a missed opportunity
instead of complaining about prices
and buying things that don't even make
sense for the dish you claim to be
making as a doctor and here's where it
is relevant that he's a medical doctor
he should be explaining to people
how to more economically buy vegetables
which most americans aren't getting
enough of buying too many processed
foods now he's a doctor who's promoted
quack cures on his show
cures for colds that are completely
unproven all sorts of weird supplements
and different things and then when he
actually has an opportunity to talk
people in a real way about nutrition uh
he talks about inflation and tries to
blame joe biden he could have gone and
said hey you know what
instead of processed foods
here's how you can get real foods
cheaply and make them last this would be
value if any member of member of
congress congress did this republican or
democrat i would applaud them this is a
big problem in the united states people
don't know what's healthy they don't
understand how to economically have
healthier foods
food products highly processed are
promoted to them he could go in and go
see this monstrous five pound bag of
carrots it's four bucks and that's a
good deal cut up some of the carrots get
hummus for three bucks that's a great
snack take some carrots and grate them
onto your salads to get more whatever i
don't remember i'm not a doctor is it
vitamin a whatever carrots have uh
beta-carotene take some carrots put a
little avocado or olive oil or even
canola oil on them salt and pepper roast
them now you've got great sides for your
lunches instead of potato chips for the
entire week
that's a great use of a five pound bag
of carrots instead it's a confused guy
claiming to be making crudite with salsa
hey let me tell you about vegetables
that are the best value in the grocery
store we should all be doing more to eat
healthy get yourself sweet potatoes get
the bulk bag roast them alongside your
carrots keep them as a side dish for
breakfast get some eggs
toss
some cubed up already cooked sweet
potato
fry an egg
and then have a handful of blueberries
or you know whatever the case may be
these are
ideas to buy in larger quantities
don't have food waste and eat healthier
than a highly processed whatever it is
you know the granola bars or whatever it
is you're having for you know sugary
cereal whatever it's really a wasted
opportunity for a doctor
to really provide something of value and
show that he's the type of voice we
should be saying we need more of that in
the senate we need this is exactly what
we need more of in the senate he does
something cheap it adds nothing to the
conversation other than playing the same
political games that's memit oz running
in pennsylvania let me know your
thoughts find me on twitter at dpakman
we'll take a quick break what a friday
program we have for you today let's
continue our tour of different races
across the country some of them scarier
than others today we're going to look at
california republican secretary of state
candidate rachel hamm who
uh has decided to run for office
because her son found jesus inside a
closet in her house
this is really wacky stuff and we are
going to look at a couple of clips of
her here is rachel hamm again candidate
for secretary of state in california
she's a republican talking to us about
how she is trying to use prayer
to steal votes back so this this is very
convoluted
she believes democrats are stealing
votes
and she's going to pray
for god to send angels to steal the
votes back now why wouldn't god just
prevent the vote theft to begin with
we'll never know but take a listen to
this i would pray that i win
yep one thing that i've been doing is
praying that if anyone tries to steal a
vote that god would send the angels to
steal the vote back to make it an honest
vote yeah i think we might as well ask i
mean the angels are you know they can do
things they can do jobs so i think we
should get a lot of them are actually in
unions they prefer union work a job with
the election help us make it an honest
one so angels if there are any fake
ballots that have been produced burn him
up find him and destroy him if votes are
flipped in the machines you know flipped
away from the candidate someone voted
for flip it back and i don't care which
way if it's from me to someone else
because that's what's honest just make
it an honest vote right so i'm not
asking for cheating i'm not asking the
angels to cheat i'm asking the angels to
prevent cheating right now with all of
these things i always kind of apply kind
of like an occam's razor thing which is
first of all if there is a god is god
really concerned with the election of
the california secretary of state or
would god be more worried about bigger
issues and then they can come back and
say well god is all-powerful and god is
all-knowing so god is involved in
everything god's involved in uh does
that banana
uh that you ate uh does did it does it
have food poisoning are you gonna get
sick from the banana or is it good god's
involved in everything okay well so why
is she even running um she explained
that she's running because of something
about jesus being in her closet
what what was the
the
reason behind deciding to run for this
office i mean you've got a lot of things
first of all i'm a prophetic dreamer so
i had spent a lot of 2019 and 20 having
a lot of political dreams that i was in
office right and because our youngest
son ezekiel is a seer i went and got him
and i said hey can you look around and
see what you're seeing because and and
now there's a real question as to
whether
her son
through heredity became a seer or
whether it's something he learned
i i just really i get a kick out of
hearing him describe you know what he
sees and so i said you know let me know
if you see anything and so he looked in
my bedroom and my bathroom and he said
there's nothing there and then he goes
into the closet which is where i had
been when i was praying right and he
said whoa and his eyes got like biggest
saucers and he kind of like started
backing away and they started bending
down and he said you've got a really big
guy in your closet and his power is
pushing me to the ground and he had
never had he'd never had that reaction
ever
to an angel and so i'm like is he he's
he's for us not against us right because
it's a different response and he's like
he's full of lie he's so full of light i
can't even see his face
and and then he said and he has a scroll
in his hand
and so i was like then he came with a
message what is the message and the
message was a commissioning so at the
very end i asked him what his name was
because
what angel is this you know and he said
emmanuel
right that wasn't an angel
i wasn't an angel that was jesus himself
so
that's why i'm running for secretary of
state yep it's kind of a she the kid
also found an angel in her washing
machine and then it turned out it was
actually um it was actually fabric
softener
uh so what do we do about that what how
what what i mean i guess hopefully she
loses we'll know that it was legit
because at this point god and jesus and
angels are so involved that if they
can't get her over the finish line
nothing can but
this is uh unfortunately this is very
common in the united states and i know
it's really scary for a lot of our
viewers around the world and for
children to hear this stuff because it
is pretty freaky
but um
that's a candidate that's a candidate
folks if you value what we do at the
david pakman show remember to support us
on patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com david pakman show
sarah palin is running for congress
sarah palin is the for our younger
viewers she was a sort of precursor to
the trump types this is this is actually
a really interesting political history
moment
bush george w bush was kind of dim
and uh
the thing about him is he's not really
all of it led to trump but he's not
really the pre-trump mold in the sense
that he was actually a neocon bush was a
neocon
palin was kind of the first what i call
sort of like uh dumacon where it's like
you're the main thing is you don't know
anything with bush he didn't know much
but he was still a neocon at heart palin
was the first sliver of what eventually
was trump and trumpism which is they're
just clueless reactionaries lacking any
real ideology and she was the late john
mccain's running mate in 2008 they
fortunately lost to barack obama and she
is now running for congress sarah palin
files to run for the late alaska
representative don young's seat
sarah palin filed with the fec on friday
for the special election she said
america is at a tipping point as i've
watched the far left destroy the country
i knew i had to step up and join the
fight
palin filed an hour before friday's
filing let deadline there are 50
candidates in the field so for the we'll
have plenty of time to talk about sarah
palin more but for those who maybe don't
remember her she was known for the word
salad before trump perfected it here's
one example from an interview in 2016
with jake tapper
a visibly disoriented sarah palin here
you talked about inconsistencies among
uh the votes and the positions of
senator cruz donald trump is somebody
who has clearly had different positions
on issues that he has today including an
issue very near and dear to your heart
the issue of abortion and life right uh
have you talked to him about that he
used to be he called himself very
pro-choice now he says he's very
pro-life i am so glad that mr trump has
seen the light and understands the the
sanctity of innocent life and how
a baby in the womb should be most
protected what has been kind of sad
about the situation though politically
speaking are groups that are pro-life
and want they say they want to bring
more people into the fold they given
trump a hard time for his past views on
abortion where they're celebrating
others like um i was going through a
list
like justin bieber
what
and um
gosh yeah yeah who who has made
that that this is jake tapper's best
moment where he looks perplexed and goes
justin bieber
yeah we i don't know either uh jake it's
understanding the the sanctity of life
but in the past he said he was no big
deal to him you know
he's just one example but i've heard
these same groups celebrate people who
have i've been to their fundraisers i've
spoken at their events and there's
usually someone in the crowd every
single one of these crowds who'll
testify to having seen the light you
know to understand oh i yeah so i'm
really hoping that she does some debates
uh here's one more example again for our
young viewers
here is sarah palin speaking at a trump
event and really just
an incredible word salad immigrants
welcoming this is like a chop chop
they've really chopped it all up and
it's just like confetti them in even
inducing and seducing them with gift
baskets come on over the border and
here's a basket of teddy bears and
soccer balls our kids and our grandkids
they'll never know then
what it is to be rewarded for that
entrepreneurial spirit that god creates
within us
in order to work and to produce and to
strive and to thrive and to really be
alive
wisconsin
reagan save the hog
here
you're harley davidson that was reagan
it made as little sense then as it does
now and we can only hope that sarah
palin will be participating in debates
so sarah palin is running another
notable race in 2020 much ahead when it
comes to the midterms let's go next to
sam from minnesota sam from minnesota
you're on the air
oh hi that's my volume your volume is
beautiful
okay um do you really think better
o'rourke is a good gubernatorial
candidate for democrats in texas you
know he had a statewide race in 2018 and
lost to ted cruz of all people and that
was before he told texans hell yeah i'm
coming for your guns so i don't really
have another candidate in mind but with
so many people in texas do you really
think beto is the best texas democrats
have to offer i don't know uh we talked
about this a little bit earlier in the
week when when on the bonus show the
topic of beto running i think what beto
has going for him are a couple different
things number one name recognition to
some degree now name recognition can be
bad as you point out if he's known to
texas republicans as the guy who wants
to take your guns so name recognition
can be a double-edged sword
um i think beto also has going for him
that
he
can definitely rebut greg abbott's
failed policy
very well and directly and eloquently
and articulately
but i don't know if he's the best person
to to run against abbott but i'm with
you in that i can't really think of
anybody else
so i'm excited about the idea that
because abbott's approval is in the
toilet
maybe someone with name recognition like
beto could actually sweep in and do a
good job obviously as i mentioned
earlier in the week they're going to run
against him on hey these democrats want
to take your guns forget about the covet
disaster forget about the electricity
disaster beto is going to take your guns
i think that could be a problem but i
don't have any better ideas right now
uh that's fair the other day you were
talking about how you felt the
interviews with families of anti-x
people who died of covid felt really
exploitative sometimes they do sometimes
they do yeah yeah well i've thought a
term i've thought of a term for that
kind of thing and i want to know what
you think of it yeah of exploitation
vaxploitation yeah i mean the thing
about it is that could mean
exploiting
people who did get it or who didn't i
mean it's not super precise but it's not
a bad idea i kind of like it yeah
yeah it's just a play on the old black
exploitation films
what about anti-vaxxploitation
uh
maybe okay it's getting a little long i
think it's a little too long yeah it
works i think you're right i think
you're right yeah no i mean do you so do
you agree that sometimes those
interviews feel a little exploitative
and like disaster porny
yeah i mean it's just the nature of you
know these new shows that are looking
for content yeah fair fair all right i
appreciate the call
oh sure sure i was about to ask you if
you think we'll be back to normal by
mid-22 but uh i think we'll be back to
normal by by mid 32.
no i have no idea i don't know i hope so
but who knows i think kova is going to
be around a couple years at least
sure thanks
all right thank you for the call
appreciate that
let's um let's speak to some other
people because there there's really a
lot of people here who want to get on
let's go next to alicia from cancun
mexico you're on the air
hello
alicia alicia from cancun you're on if
you unmute will be able to hear you
and last opportunity for alicia slash
alicia from cancun you must unmute to
speak to me
otherwise the tubes won't work
all right that's too bad
let's stay in cancun and go to eric from
cancun instead eric are you on the air
hmm
eric from cancun you're on
wow
something must be going on with the
internet there
in uh in cancun let's go next to i hope
i'm pronouncing this correctly is it
ishan from amherst
yeah that's correct hey david how's it
going it's going well thank you thanks
for picking up my phone call um
so my question to you is on sunday the
parliamentarian elizabeth mcdonough
ruled that the democrats can't include
all the immigration provisions in the
reconciliation bill now
the
um senate majority leader chuck schumer
and dick durbin they're all being like
oh we have plan b we're gonna go back to
her with another proposal
my question to you is why are they
begging an unelected official why can't
they simply overrule her or ignore her
um i know that in 2001 republicans did
the same thing they probably fired the
parliamentarian when millions of lives
are at stake
um do you have any do you know like why
are they just like not playing hardball
and like just like ignoring her all
together
i agree with you completely this notion
that now is sort of like just assumed to
be true
that the parliamentarian just gets to
decide uh i i i challenge that and i've
read a couple of good pieces arguing
that
you don't re it's sort of like by
tradition
that the parliamentarian is given
um uh the ability to weigh in on these
things and that times have sort of
changed and that quite frankly i mean
this term has a negative connotation but
they could just steamroll the
parliamentarian if they wanted and then
deal with it later let republicans say
i'm against it because it's out of order
right or whatever but i completely agree
with you and i think it's ridiculous the
way they're handling the parliamentarian
but do you think there's any chance with
joe mentioned christian cinema and
in the senate
that um they're gonna even like think
about um
bringing the bill with the provisions on
the floor and let kamala harris just
ignore her ruling
um
i i don't i think it depends on the bill
to be perfectly honest i'm not sure i
think it depends i think there maybe yes
i'd have to think a little more about
that
hey thank you so much david thank you so
much for taking my phone call um i don't
know if you remember but like i called
last year too i would talk but yeah
probably not but
remind me sean are you in amherst
massachusetts or amherst new york
amherst massachusetts i go to umass oh
you do oh my god i just heard 350
positive cases last week at umass
yeah there was like a party in an
off-campus gathering town houses yeah um
honestly speaking
if i'm gonna level with you i've stopped
caring because i feel like there's
nothing i can do people are gonna party
left and right yeah uh
i i can't help it so like there's no
point like thinking about it just like
it just it's not conducive to my own
well-being i cannot focus on those jobs
i totally sympathize with that
which which town houses was the party at
um the town houses which is like in
sunderland oh those town oh wow okay
okay yeah yeah yeah that was like a mass
congregation and i feel like there's
nothing i can do that that's gonna
change to drive the numbers one way or
the other yeah so what's the point of
stressing out about it i am fully
vaccinated i take care of myself i just
like i'm just moving on i just like
live my own life whatever happens
happens i i can't do anything at this
point i understand ishaan it sounds like
you're doing all the right things anyway
so
yeah thank you so much all right
pleasure there's ishan from umass
my undergraduate alma mater wow what a
call
what a call
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
now let's go to something that is very
very good for trump this is genuinely
scary
the pennsylvania gubernatorial race also
had its primary yesterday now on the
democratic side running unopposed is the
state's attorney general josh shapiro a
relatively unremarkable democrat
smart from everything i've seen
likeable
perfectly reasonable uncontroversial guy
just normal guy would be a normal
governor on the other side on the
republican side the winner of the uh
gubernatorial primary is a guy named
doug mastriano who pretty easily won
with a 24 point margin over the second
place candidate lou barletta doug
mastriano is an
dangerous weaponized conspiracy theorist
trumpist
who was in washington dc at the capitol
on january 6th who has promulgated
so-called stop the steel conspiracies
who has played coy with q and on
phraseology
and remember that the governor appoints
the secretary of state the person in
charge of running pennsylvania's
elections
uh this is really scary stuff really
really scary stuff um two there we have
this interesting uh
report about masteriano two days before
the capital riots mastriano said he was
heading to washington dc and calling out
to god for divine revelation he used
campaign funds to charter six buses to
shuttle followers to dc and told them he
would speak on the capitol steps around
one o'clock rioters broke into the
capitol some wielding bibles jesus 2020
signs an appeal to heaven flags and
shofars we'll get back to shofars on the
senate floor one insurrectionist called
out from the day is jesus christ we
invoke your name
and of course you know the rest of uh of
what happened on january 6. so this is a
wacky guy he was there for the stop the
steel rally ahead of the riots he tried
to conduct one of these arizona style
partisan reviews of the election results
in pennsylvania he made debunked
conspiracy theory claims about the
election
a sort of centerpiece of his campaign in
pennsylvania he was going to speak at a
q anon branded con conference called
patriots arise in june of 21 ended up
not doing it because of the chaos and
the media that was generated from the
news that he would be speaking there and
the republicans know it's really big
that mastriano won rudy for example was
celebrating it posting i think this was
on truth social rudy giuliani writing
tonight the biggest win
is doug mastriano in pennsylvania he's a
veteran an historian and a true patriot
the most important quality in this
election is guts to destroy the democrat
express train to marxism and the rhinos
who enable it so the press will write
nice things about them doug will be to
pennsylvania what trump was for the
united states and he's not wrong they
are putting the insurrectionists inside
the house
um mastriano is disgusting here's one
wacky video back in um
january
when masteriano announced he was running
they opened the event
with the blowing of a shofar now i don't
know how many of you know what a shofar
is a shofar is a ram's horn it's an
element of the jewish faith and it's
used uh to signify sometimes the sabbath
uh sometimes the end of the fasting
period at yom kippur and there's
actually a history of masteriano
misusing uh jewish symbols this was the
start of the campaign from austrian this
people
i believe god
is about to manifest himself brother
he has to because we cannot keep going
the way we're going
amen
[Music]
dear god
[Music]
okay
so uh masteriano is not jewish and he
has this history of misusing jewish
symbols as campaign props back uh in
april he spoke and raised money at a far
right christian conference called
patriots arise for god and country
and they promoted conspiracy theories
including
the existence of a global cabal of sex
trafficking democrats you guys have
heard this stuff before 911 was a false
flag vaccines are genocide therapy
adolf hitler faked his death and once
again jewish organizations criticized
that for the improper use of campaign
props they also used a shofar there so
this is a disgusting guy and he's a
dangerous guy
the 2024 election
could come down to pennsylvania and if
doug mastriano gets to decide who runs
that election it's a really really bad
thing so pennsylvania
is becoming a major area of focus
we should support josh shapiro for
governor we should support john
fetterman for senator now the good news
is for now that recently democrats tend
to win the governorship in pennsylvania
so if we look at some recent elections
in 2018 the democrat tom wolf won easily
by 17 points in 2014 the democrat tom
wolf won easily by about nine points in
2010 a republican did win tom corbett
won by about nine points but then in 20
2006 ed rendell
ran away with it with a 21-point win so
the hope is
that it's just an overwhelming
democratic gubernatorial victory in
pennsylvania if not
we're really up for it and there's many
different important races
months ago we said pennsylvania will be
a focus pennsylvania's gubernatorial
race is quite literally a referendum on
democracy this is as big as any other
issue just
do you support a democratic system and
if you do
you've got to vote for josh shapiro and
if people are looking to phone bank in a
particular race
that is a race that is of significant
interest meanwhile one bit of good
gubernatorial news from yesterday
far-right idaho gubernatorial candidate
janice mcgeechen
uh maybe is pronounced mcgeeken i don't
know
she lost in idaho and that is a very
good thing so initial results a mixed
bag many more primaries coming next
tuesday six days from today and of
course we'll be covering all of it live
and just a quick reminder monday
memorial day we're doing a one-day
membership special we are blowing
members we might run out of memberships
okay we are going to offer an incredible
discount off of memberships on our
website our primary funding source on
monday memorial day if you want to be
notified of how to get the discounted
membership just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
we have been starting to pay closer
attention to particular 2022 midterm
races we're following
just to name a few
the florida gubernatorial race where
potential 2024 presidential candidate
ron desantis is up for re-election as
governor
we on monday night
had a live stream of in the pennsylvania
senate we first had the democratic
primary debate and then we had the
republican primary debate the republican
primary debate is the one where memit oz
the um
uh
tv doctor is running we covered that and
it was cringy and it was wacky in a lot
of different ways
another particularly disturbing race
is the arizona house race
wherein in the first arizona
congressional district a guy named ron
watkins is running we've talked about
ron watkins before
ron watkins is a
a roughly
35 34 year old conspiracy theorist he's
the site administrator administrator and
um
i guess we i think he's the owner as
well
of the website 8k un this is formerly
8chan
and he has played a major role in
spreading
all sorts of far-right q anon conspiracy
theories he is now running
in arizona's first congressional
district he was in a debate last night
hosted by arizona state university and
the local pbs station and there is
something about this guy
that is
cringe-worthy and extraordinarily creepy
i don't know exactly what it is i'm
going to look at a couple of clips here
with you first just a very strange
moment from his opening statement where
he kind of seems to lose his train of
thought but it's all just weird and i
will make sure that your rights are
are kept
thank you okay so the entire the entire
thing got off to a very very strange
start
now then the question of ukraine came up
military aid to ukraine
ron watkins tried to blame the keystone
xl pipeline
for the invasion
and this um
uh led to one of the other candidates
representative blackman
to basically crush watkins and he
crushed him so brutally that watkins had
no choice to go actually i misspoke my
opponent is correct this is fascinating
check this out let's hear the aid to
ukraine what do you think ron i support
military uh aid to ukraine but i want to
say that we would not even be in ukraine
if president biden did not shut down the
keystone pipeline on the first day what
because
now that that's shut down we have to get
our oil and we're getting it from russia
and we're getting
all these problems through the ukraine
and that would not have happened if
biden did not so you see the ukraine so
this is a word salad this is of no he is
visibly struggling to use english to
communicate substance and he is failing
the the the pipeline
helped prompt russia to invade ukraine
yes sir because we've got all of this
oil coming through from russia to the
united states and
they want the better routes to bring the
oil through can i can i clarify
this is what i'm talking about that's
not why they went into ukraine ukraine
they went into ukraine because ukraine
didn't want to be part of nato listen
you're trying to be you're trying to
work on the national stage and you don't
even know why the war started in ukraine
it had nothing to do with the keystone
pipeline the keystone pipeline caused
the inflation and the increase in our
gas prices
that's also not true that so they're
both wrong but but i mean this this is
just bizarre they went in to ukraine is
because russia
wanted ukraine as they had them
pre-world war ii and ukraine wanted to
be part of nato respond please
he's right i made a mistake yeah there
you go so i mean
listen
if there's anything to praise ron
watkins for here
um
it's that he immediately said yeah what
i just said is completely untrue it's
absolutely and completely untrue in
another weird moment ron watkins claimed
that the biggest issue in uh the
congress is is it the first or second
congressional just now i don't even
remember they he said that the biggest
issue is the border wall even though
this part of arizona isn't actually near
the border and then he claims that he
went to the border and scared coyotes
away coyotes not literal
actually i think he means coyotes in
terms of like people smugglers i don't
think he means literal coyotes but let's
listen biggest issue for this district
is the border wall the border wall was
not completed and there are actually
sections of it that were destroyed
and i went down to those sections and i
asked the locals how did this section of
the border wall get destroyed right and
they told me that biden sent the army
corps of engineers down there to destroy
the border wall for flood for flood
prevention
issues so i went down there and i saw
with my own eyes i saw the coyotes
sitting right across the border the
coyotes looked me in the eyes and they
ran away right they were so scared when
when uh ron watkins went down there so
bizarre stuff and lest anybody think
that ron watkins is the only wacky
candidate
then the moderator asked representative
walt blackman about his history of
wanting to
charge
people women seeking abortions and the
doctors performing them with homicide
and he says he still supports that so
it's not only ron watkins that's off the
rails i read that you have said that you
said abortion doctors and women who get
abortions should be charged with
homicide exactly you know that's already
in our statute arizona statute if a
person commits abortion or kills a baby
while in the womb it's under our
criminal statute i didn't make the law
up the law has already been there what i
did was codify that law now
going back and changing that and
amending that what i have done is allow
women to be able to seek services
counseling services
for what they need now here's the deal
so basically he's willing not to charge
women with murder
if instead they go to one of these
counseling services
where
the by the way the term counselor is not
a regulated term it's not a therapist
where they go to like a christian
counselor who talks you out of getting
the abortion there are more babies being
aborted and born every day now the
problem that i see is that that is not
part of the conversation and if i have
to do something to save the black
community of babies being aborted in a
record number guess what i'm going to do
it but we need to save all babies when
we have states like california and new
york that are pushing late term abortion
that are pushing and fantasize and we
stand and do and remember know what no
one's pushing it nothing it's time for
us to take a stand for life it's time
for us to get on the side of god and
it's time for us to protect these
children that are being murdered in the
womb homicide at what level how far did
the pregnancy be when it's homicide
conception conception conception yes sir
okay can you imagine
homicide
for a you know five-week abortion
this is this is some people don't like
this term this is dark ages uh dark ages
stuff
um okay one more clip the moderator asks
or one two more clips the moderator asks
ron watkins how would you have reacted
as a congressman on the day of the trump
riots i'll start with you how would you
have reacted as a congressman on january
6th
on january 6 as a congressman i would
have
texted president trump and told him
please call this off
because it got out of hand pretty
quickly do you think he had the power to
do that
he did call it off but he took a while
to do this if he had the power to call
it off do you think he had the power to
call it on
i don't know uh
so he had invited all these people out
there
and surely
uh there must have been some kind of
intel going on but
i don't i don't know it was meant to be
a peaceful uh protest
and there were some people that got in
there and did some bad things and
those people should be prosecuted the
ones that did the bad things but right
for the majority of the people that were
there 99.99
it was a peaceful protest and there was
no issue so 99.99 of the people that we
saw on television storming the u.s
capitol walking the halls defacing the
capital these were well i just told you
that there were people doing bad things
and there were millions of people there
and there was just a few people that
really i've seen oh yeah the people at
that uh rally and at the capitol
millions yes sir yeah there were not
millions of people there as of course we
all know um and then lastly here ron
watkins actually asked about his
relationship to q anon he just denies
the entire thing ron some people say
that a lot of this was stoked by q anon
what is your relationship with q anon i
have no relationship with q anon none at
all none at all um the reports are that
your bulletin board sites hosted
postings that launched and launched a q
on conspiracy so i ran a free speech
website and i was the administrator
and there were many thousands of
thousands of people that posted on those
sites
uh q was just one of those and i do not
know who it was and i'm not that person
yeah of course he spent months and
months and months parroting human on
stuff in uh cringeworthy fashion so the
closer we look at a lot of these
individual races it's all bad choices
it's bad
and then worse and unfortunately a lot
of these people may end up winning in
november we'll have these clips on our
instagram at david pakman show who
though for those who are gluttons for
punishment and want to take